look the devil works hard God damn it
Chris Jenner Works harder that woman is
dude but she sold her daughter's sex tap
I but but would you really call that
love for your daughter no that's what
I'm saying that's what I'm that's also
what I'm trying say this is what I'm
telling to you if if
I that is
so so far beyond that that people have
just forgotten that she sold her
daughter's sex
tape and that some that somehow she just
walks Among Us like a [__] normal
human it's all and also like people it's
funny cuz like if you're a Kardashian
fan you I mean not only if you're a
Kardashian fan do you idolize that
family but you really idolize Chris
Jenner like I I I I feel like a lot of
people who love that family like love
her especially